Are you gonna tell us where the bomb is?
Or are we gonna have to beat it out of you?
No.  No, you don't have to beat me.  Please.  I'll tell you.
It's four three two
nine two
eight one two one nine.
...what?
I...what?
The coordinates.
(gasps) Oh...shoot.
Did you write that down?
No, I thought he was just like giving us his phone number or something.
I don't have a pen and paper, do you have one?
No, I left my purse in the car.
Uhm.  The bomb is going to go off in like a minute.
The only thing I asked you to bring today was a pen and paper.
I know!  But there's like nowhere to put it!  This thing is so tight.
I don't know--in your bra!
That would give me a boob bulge.
You know, I just want to point out that a lot of people are going to die if we don't disarm this bomb soon.
Ok, ok!  Yes.  So maybe--could you just repeat those coordinates one more time?
Yea yea, totally.
432-92-81219
432-81...
I think it was 91.
This is so many numbers to memorize, we're never gonna do it.
Oh!  Why don't we turn it into as song?
(gasps) I love songs!
Ok, sorry.  Could you just repeat it one more time?
432.
432!
92.
92!
81219.
(together) 81219!
432! 92! 81219!
Oh shit.
That's not where he was.
Wow.
*sigh*
We should go find the bomb!
Oh!  Let's find that bomb!
Are you sure this is right?
Yes!  431-92-81219
*explosion and screaming*
*police sirens*